bonjour les principaux titres de ce
journal de 13h pour raymond barre la
hausse des prix en septembre n'est pas
catastrophique mais le gouvernement va
sans doute réagir dès le début de la
semaine prochaine
le premier ministre retour de hongrie
les impressions de voyage de georges
bortoli qui l'a suivi les avocats des
otages français du polisario sont à
alger serge me serait celui pour nous
les négociations et puis à la fin de ce
journal deux enquêtes l'une sérieux sur
l'expérience unique du lycée de moutier
l'école du champion de ski l'autre un
peu moins sur la présence des pompiers
de paris dans un spectacle de music-hall
patienter quelques minutes si vous allez
comprendre
le détail donc avec la bonne nouvelle
pour commencer de ce week-end la météo
décidément rien n'est plus comme avant
même le temps n'est plus de saison
la météo a fait plus et mieux pour les
français qui bouge et ils sont 5
millions à prendre leur voiture pendant
ce long week-end après la dissipation
des brouillards très dense qui
enveloppait la plupart des régions ce
matin sans compter les jeux les blanches
dans l'est et le centre de la france le
soleil va en mettre un rayon pour
dissiper ces brumes
mais il n'y parviendra que dans la
journée dans l'après midi et cela sauf
sur les côtes de la manche où il y aura
quelques plus les températures vont
rester stationnaire le minimum c'était 3
à nancy ce matin et le maximum 13 à
cannes à nice et à perpignan la hausse
des prix au mois de septembre n'a rien
de catastrophique a donc expliqué hier
soir monsieur raymond barre dans l'avion
qui le ramenait de hongrie le premier
ministre va quand même réunir au début
de la semaine prochaine
une sorte de conseil de guerre sur les
prix avec les principaux ministres
intéressés
on peut attendre que tu attends de ce
conseil de guerre sans aucun doute une
série de mesures
car si la hausse modérée des prix
manufacturés est satisfaisante
si la hausse importante des prix
pharmaceutiques étaient voulues celle
des produits alimentaires est en grande
partie responsable de cet indice de 0
29%
je ne veux pas porter de jugement
définitif sur les causes de la hausse
des prix des produits alimentaires savez
ce n'est jamais sain je viens de lire
dans un journal de paris que l'on m'a
apporté et tout à l'heure c'est la faute
des structures commerciales
c'est la faute des circuits de
distribution en un sens il y à ce
facteur
mais il n'est pas le seul et il faut
surtout se garder dans ce genre de
situation d' analyse sommaire et
simpliste qui conduisent à des mesures
sommaire et simpliste qui réjouissent
quelques esprits superficiels pendant
quelques jours mais qui ensuite parce
qu'elles ne sont pas efficaces parce
qu'elles ne correspondent pas l'objet
recherché apparaissent comme des mesures
tout à fait insuffisantes comme l'outil
pourtant monsieur prémunissent qu'une
prenais part de suite des mesures pour
stopper l'augmentation des produits
alimentaires votre indice 1 toujours des
ratés
'l'indice va déraper
si les facteurs qui sont les facteurs
internationaux et des facteurs nationaux
sur lesquels nous ne pouvons rien
continue à se manifester
je voudrais vous poser la question
monsieur puisque vous me posez eu
comment pouvez vous empêcher linguiste
dérapé en ce qui concerne les prix des
produits alimentaires
si le prix du cacao du café continue à
augmenter
si vous me donner la recette je vais
vous donner une décoration à montbard a
donc fait cette déclaration dans l'avion
qui le ramenait de budapest hier soir où
il vient d'effectuer une visite
officielle de trois jours
utile couronnée de succès et prometteuse
pour l'avenir titre ce matin les
journaux hongrois à propos de la visite
objectif essentiel pour les deux pays
doubler leurs échanges commerciaux dans
les plus brefs délais georges bortoli
vous êtes revenu donc hier soir dans un
avion plus premier ministre vous l'avez
suivi pendant trois jours
oui ce voyage qui s'est bien passé en ce
sens au sein n'a pas été un voyage tendu
à voyage difficile c'est un voyage
souriant il a même vu pas mal de sourire
sur le visage de monsieur jan schnider
est d'habitude un visage assez tendue et
presque tragique
monsieur barre de son côté m'a paru très
favorablement impressionné par le
sérieux des dirigeants hongrois en
particulier dans le domaine économique
il faut dire que monsieur kadaré son
équipe comme on dirait jantes un maître
mot c'est l'efficacité il n'hésite pas à
supprimer par exemple des entreprises
non rentables pour mettre à la place des
entreprises rentables qu'ils sont
capables d'exporter ses longs qu'une
médecine économique est très rude mais
apparemment payante puisque la hongrie
se flatte d'avoir un niveau de vie
supérieur à celui de la plupart des pays
socialistes d'europe de l'est
et je crois que c'est en cela en fin de
compte que ceux situés l'intérêt de ce
voyage et son côté je dirais presque
agréable c'était un voyage dans un pays
qui est ouvert à la coopération
internationale qui est ouvert à la
détente est aussi et peut-être surtout
qui est ouvert la coopération économique
les échanges commerciaux
et puis on marche donc de la politique
qu'à la fin de ce voyage monsieur
malabar sont allés se détendre en se
replongeant pendant quelques heures dans
dont les traditions du pays magyar dans
la pousse dans la grande plaine
hongroise madame barre à retrouver
l'endroit où elle passait ses vacances
quand elle était une petite finale
je n'ai pas voulu m ortho badji est à la
fois un parc national et une florissante
d'exploitation de 43 mille hectares où
l'on élève des chevaux de course parmi
les meilleurs du monde
du folklore pas forcément ici
l'exploitation rationnelle l'élevage
moderne se mélangent aux très vieille
tradition magar comme dans cette belle
démonstration de dressage
et quel meilleur souvenir garder de la
grande plaine hongroise qu'un fou et le
cavalier 12 heures après l'expiration de
l'ultimatum concernant monsieur carranza
l'homme d'affaires hollandais enlevé
vendredi matin à amsterdam ultimatum
fixé au téléphone par un correspondant
prétendant parler au nom de la fraction
armée rouge
l'avis de monsieur 40 ha contre la
libération d'un terroriste
rien de nouveau ce matin la police pense
qu'il s'agit là d'un vulgaire d'une
vulgaire affaire criminelle est donc une
opération politique
et puis dans la sphère des otages
français du polisario
l'un des coopérants enlevés par les
sahraouis avaient écrit à sa femme juste
avant de disparaître
la région n'est pas sûr il y à des raids
aériens après 2o et rate le fusil
mitrailleur crash
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing a fait
savoir à madame miguet les pousses de ce
coopérant enlever ce qu'il suivait
personnellement cette affaire et que
toutes les démarches possibles été
prises actuellement pour un dénouement
heureux
on sait le depuis hier qu'une force
d'intervention est un état d' alerte
mais le précise le ministère de la
défense cela se produit chaque fois que
sur gîte un problème mettant en jeu les
intérêts de la france pendant ce temps à
alger les avocates des otages français
essaient d'entrer en contact avec le
polisario cierges me serais et sur place
toute organisation
la politique c'est avant tout ce
week-end à villeurbanne la suite des
travaux du congrès des maires
socialistes et républicains d'un art
pradino vous venez l'écouter à l'instant
le discours prononcé par françois
mitterrand alors monsieur mitterrand a
voulu à la fois encourager les
socialistes et résonner les communistes
l'encouragement c'est l'affirmation de
la force du parti socialiste
notre parti est solide il n'a pas de
problèmes internes et il peut compter au
moins sur 7 millions de voix ce qu'il
faut dit monsieur mitterrand maintenance
et porter la bonne parole partout en
france mobilisé l'ensemble du parti ses
militants ses parlementaires ces comités
pour une campagne nationale
d'information
c'est d'ailleurs ce que savait
actuellement le parti communiste qui a
déjà engagé une grande campagne
d'explication et de justification à
propos du désaccord entre les parties du
corps les deuxième aspect donc il faut
raisonner les communistes alors résonner
les communistes et dire à monsieur
marchait ne faites pas le jeu de la
majorité
on ne peut pas se contenter de refuser
l'union de la gauche on ne peut pas se
contenter de détruire parce qu'alors
c'est la majorité qui l'emportera est ce
que les travailleurs auront les
avantages que leur propose la gauche
avec la majorité du gouvernement actuel
non évidemment répond monsieur
mitterrand alors il prévient monsieur
marchait n'endosse est pas la
responsabilité d'un échec électoral
est ce que cela veut dire que c'est la
fin de la guerre froide entre le parti
communiste et parti socialiste qui est
proche
on n'en sait rien hier déjà monsieur
mermaz qui lui est un proche de monsieur
mitterrand affirmait un accord est
encore possible avec les communistes
hier également à villeurbanne monsieur
moreau a précisé que les socialistes
étaient prêts à reprendre les
conversations demain à noël au mois de
janvier
n'importe quand pourvu qu'il soit encore
temps sinon et c'est encore monsieur
mauroy qui ait dit cela
sinon les socialistes ont obligé de
définir un programme de gouvernement
leur propre programme
après le premier tour des législatives
et c'est alors l'électeur de gauche qui
tranchera merci bernard pradines nous
reviendrons dans notre journal de 20h
sur ce discours de françois mitterrand
et d'ex des des extraits du discours et
les commentaires de daniel brands
quelques petites phrases politiques
pendant ce week-end andré boulloche du
parti socialiste pense que les relations
parti communiste parti socialiste ont
toujours été conflictuelle que si l'on
excepte la lune de miel des
présidentielles monsieur mono du rpr dit
qu'il n'y a pratiquement aucun désaccord
au sein de la majorité pour les
législatives il déplore quand même les
candidatures de certains ministres
notamment celle de madame soigner ses
hits et et celle de monsieur lionel
stoléru jacques chirac de son côté a
expliqué que lier le problème du chômage
à la présence des immigrés est une
réaction primaire en tant que maire de
paris il estime que le pourcentage
d'étrangers résidant à paris
18% et raisonnable pour une ville qui se
veut cosmopolite l'école des champions
un slogan qui pourrait être gravée sur
le fronton du lycée de moutier en savoie
il y avait déjà les section sport études
ou des lycéens pratiquer une discipline
sportive en poursuivant leurs études
il ya maintenant de cette expérience
unique de moutier ou de jeunes skieurs
de très haut niveau
partagent leur année en deux temps le
ski cela va commencer dans quelques
jours
et puis l'année scolaire et cela à
partir du 15 avril
coût 7
comme c est pour ces élèves
ils sont une soixantaine garçons et
filles plus excellent skieur l'année
scolaire commencera le 15 avril pour
s'achever le 15 novembre
ils passeront le bac en même temps que
leurs camarades des lycées français de
l'hémisphère sud sélectionné par la
fédération française de ski ils vont
bénéficier en plus du programme habituel
de 13 heures d'éducation physique par
semaine un rythme scolaire à la carte
le ski l'hiver les études l'été un
professeur pour une dizaine d'élèves la
section expérimentale du lycée de
moutier semble répondre à une politique
élite est évident que dans une certaine
mesure on peut parler d'une élite mais
il faut bien considérer qu'il s'agit là
de jeunes filles et de jeunes gens qui
au départ sont extrêmement doués pour la
pratique du ski et à qui il importait de
données et une formule 1 qui leur
permettent justement de se réaliser dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
vous avez l'impression que c'est une
expérience qui est destiné plus servir
le ski où est servi en intérêt
professionnel des élèves ont écouté je
pense que ça va servir le skill bien
entendu mais nous en tant qu
établissement scolaire nous nous plaçons
essentiellement reste dans le domaine
pédagogique mais scolaire puisque
voulons c'est les amener au baccalauréat
aux différents packs à l'horaire dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
melesse meilleur 1 voit la différence
belley
pour la fédération française de ski le
premier objectif est de fabriquer des
skis et les responsables de l'équipe de
france déçu par ces derniers résultats
attendent beaucoup du lycée de moutier
marque finale pas très brun way
l'intérieur les études la compétition
n'étant plus là conciliables les élèves
vont devenir les champions de demain les
jeunes qui rentrent maintenant ne sont
pas encore tous dans l'équipe de france
il y en a certains qui sont déjà en
particulier surtout niveau des
terminales cette année mais pour
l'avenir
absolument certain que ceci va nous
apporter un nouveau recrutement comme en
équipe de france
vous avez eu du mal à l'obtenir auprès
du ministère d'éducation
mais non je trouvais des véritables
pionniers au niveau des ministères
éducation et des gens qui sont vraiment
prêts à entreprendre
se pencher sur des formules nouvelles
est vraiment à mettre en place de
nouvelles structures
on aurait apprécié oui parce qu'à mon
époque
ça fait nombreux années on était plutôt
sanctionner si on faisait du sport oui
c'est une chance je pense c'est une
chance incroyable
les jeunes ont maintenant c'est
fantastique de pouvoir est envisagé la
compétition au plus haut niveau si
évidemment sion sur le mérite et puis
pouvoir avoir le soulagement le la
tranquillité d'esprit de pouvoir
poursuivre des études parce que c'est
c'est une nécessité qui nous a manqué
beaucoup nous à notre époque parce qu'on
n'a pas pu jouer cette carte-là
transition toute trouvée le sport
maintenant en boxe guy caudron a
reconquis son titre de champion de
france des poids coq en battant hier
soir jacky been par jet de l'épongé la
cinquième reprise
toujours dans la même catégorie le
mexicain zahrat a conservé son titre de
champion du monde en battant le
brésilien baptiste en football la
pologne qui a fait match nul hier soir
avec le portugal 0 à 0 et le huitième
pays qualifiés pour l'argentine pour la
coupe du monde
pour mémoire les résultats du
championnat de france de division 2 le
groupe a d'abord avec une victoire à
l'extérieur celle de besançon qui a
battu auxerre à auxerre 2 à 0 cet après
midi il ya trois matches cannes
haguenau arleux chaumont et ajaccio
toulon groupe b les voici deux victoires
à l'extérieur dunkerque a battu caen 3-1
et le red star qui a battu lui c'est 2 à
0 au classement du groupe b lille est en
tête devant tours devant le red star
troisième à un point il y avait aussi du
basket ball
hier soir voici les principaux résultats
les vainqueurs caen tours le mans
challans et berck les détails évidemment
sur tous ces événements sportifs dans
stade 2 à 19h sur antenne 2 et puis à
mi-chemin entre le sport et le spectacle
la performance réalisée presque tous les
soirs par les trente pompiers de paris
qui ont été engagés dans un spectacle de
music hall pour une nouvelle boîte de
nuit qui vient de s'ouvrir sur les
champs elysées les pompiers entouraient
de danseurs et de danseuses en tenue
et gère un événement inhabituel que
france roche n'a pas laissé passer
sur la scène du jardin de paris un
tableau de circus polio avait tout ce
qu'il faut de donneurs est nu et de
jeunes gens de toutes sortes également
peu habillée traditionnel mais en
coulisses du nouveau ses pompiers avec
qui la trouvent fraternisent ne sont pas
venus éteindre un feu quelque part ils
font aussi partie du programme
dans leur loge sous le regard de
l'adjudant-chef pas de fautes en une
seule coquetterie des baskets ap karl
cette brigade spéciale est recruté comme
ans parmi les meilleurs gymnastes parmi
les meilleurs gymnastes de oui et c'est
à dire que nous arrivons nous avons deux
mois d'instruction bon pied et après ces
deux mois nous passeront un test de
gymnastique et les meilleurs sont pris
ils participent aux services d'incendié
ont un petit creux leurs camarades dans
le 15e vous êtes déjà allé au feu je
suis déjà loupé dans une période de
garde c'est à dire après les
entraînements
vous avez mois le trac au feu que quand
vous allez sur la scène j'ai un peu plus
peur quand je vous fais venir c'est
sympa
si au décolleté comme ce prix le savoir
qu'on avait passé de la cam à l'aise ça
c'est la grande surprise pour tout le
monde est à la baisse
disons que ça change quoi des fêtes
champêtres
le numéro qui est payé par la boîte de
nuit est réglée alors à la préfecture à
la wii est là parce que je voulais ce
qu'une convention nous rions eternal
terrain alors à venir se fatiguer un peu
aux six se permet de
montez au parisien fait les roquettes
faris compter
allemand des athlètes justement d'après
leur condition physique elle se sentir
en toute sécurité
salaire de base de 1500 francs par mois
pour 4 100 points de service public en
même temps qu'ils assurent le service
incendie font des déplacements et alors
point de vue dit famille ils ont montré
pauli alors quelques fois de temps en
temps nous qui aimons femme ne voit
aucun inconvénient à ce que vous alliez
vous produire dans les boîtes de nuit
avec des femmes nues
une des questions que pose au début mais
on a pu ranger les choses
est ce qu'il ya des blessés quelquefois
dans le cours du numéro sa rivale russe
est arrivé si d'ailleurs s'était
fracassé envie de quitter le corps des
pompiers pour vous mettre dans sa alors
non pas du tout c'est un lieu qui ne
m'attire pas
je suis
pour terminer ce journal une petite
scène de l'actualité de tous les jours
mais qui est digne de la lorgnette
comment faire pour résister à une
agression
réponse d'une jeune citoyenne américaine
de saint-louis regard des premières
photos au moment où elle entre dans sa
voiture dans un parking un homme se
précipite et essaie de lui voler son sac
à main deuxième photo loin d'être des
appareils contre attaque de la dame elle
prend son mors aux dents je sais pas si
vous la voyez très bien d'ailleurs des
gemmes poussé un tout petit peu voilà
elle prend son mordant donc et elle l
attaque au bras elle mord le bras du
gangster une arme communaux de
finalement je me retrouve à 20 heures
pour le prochain journal je vous
souhaite une très bonne après midi sur
antenne 2